for more information on tutoring or how
to support move university and the
production of more videos please visit
moof university comm thank you and enjoy
so this is question is what are the
energies associated with the orbitals
we've mentioned and the answer that
question depends so if you're talking
about the hydrogen atom which is what
this video is particularly going to
cover the the orbital is all of the
orbitals with the same principal quantum
number which is n all the orbitals with
the same principal quantum number n have
the same energy they are all of equal
energy and they are thus said to be
degenerate ok so that's a special case
or situation now why is this it's
specifically because the hydrogen atom
has only one electron has only one
electron so there is no shielding which
we'll kind of talk about in the next
video I'll get to what that means later
but the way that's sort of depicted with
all these orbitals the same principle
quantum number having the same energies
like this if we think about this axis
here this arrow pointing up to mean
energy increasing right to bottom here
the lowest energy level is one then
there's two and there's three now all of
the orbitals in that energy level right
the principal quantum number have the
same energy in the hydrogen atom it's a
very special case so there's only one s
there's only one orbital in the in the
first shell in the second shell there's
a 2's over one the 2p orbital in the
hydrogen I don't have the same energy
that's the same level of energy if you
go up to the third one we've got the 3 s
the 3 3 PS and the 5 3 D orbitals and
they're all at the same energy level ok
so if you have a hydrogen atom has one
electron if it's in its ground state
which means it's not excited then it has
one electron in the 1s orbital once
considered at the ground state kind of
looks like that
okay where all these other all these
other orbitals are the same energy level
if they're same they have the same
energy if they're at the same energy
level they have the same principle
quantum number so if I put the 4s 4p 4d
and 4f orbitals they would all also have
the same energy so so that's the
hydrogen atom now in other atoms with
more than one electron more than one
electron
they're called multi-electron atoms also
known as many electron atoms or poly
electronic atoms they have more than one
electron that's not the case not all the
orbitals is the same principle quantum
number have the same energy in
multi-electron atoms to explain why that
is though we must first explore and
understand two things electron shielding
and effective nuclear charge which is
what we'll talk about in the next video
so I hope that video is helpful thank
you for watching if you found that video
helpful don't forget to like comment
subscribe and share with friends thank
you and happy studying